you if you into the States United States
America and you're driving a Ferrari
everyone will congratulate you nice man
what do you do for a living how can I do
that if you're in the UK driving a
Ferrari the same they'll just call your
wanker the European spirit yeah behind
it the same time yeah but all and then
as a result of that successful people
don't then want to be over the top with
their successes oh my gosh I just got a
pay rise oh my gosh because then how's
that going to make everybody else feel
well forget that because they should
feel inspired and if they're not
inspired if they're jealous then you
wanted to track them out of your life
anyway so make them jealous what I do is
I I tell people big energy equals big
bank because everyone wants a big bank
yeah every bank so and it's so true
and when people link actually me having
a certain type of energy is gonna lead
to me having better results health
results me being more successful me
having more friends even friends if you
go to a party you missed a nerve energy
standing around like a freakin loser
guess what you're not gonna you're not
gonna have any friends no one's gonna
want to spend Tommy they're not gonna
make people feel good you go to a party
you've got a good energy and you love
people yeah it's just a track you have
tracked people so and you attract what
you become so I think rather than sort
of telling people you know our energy is
important everything is energy as a
theoretical thing for people just to be
like okay that's weird it's more like
hey what do you want in your life are
you want more money okay you wanted more
information you want to get promotions
at work
you want to get fit body you want to get
a thick girlfriend whatever it might be
you want to get like an evil to attract
that and to attract you better become it
and to become it you've got to have a
lot of energy but other what kind of
energy because honestly sometimes people
I would not want to spend time with
people they haven't said a word they'll
walk into the room just Energy Star
website yeah I'm just allergic to the
energy of that person know I'm feel the
same I'm sure I've checked out yeah
there was that so hard
give him a chance none of them they did
that to themself why have you answered
such a such a repulsive energy so how do
you clean yourself from bad energy mmm -
good energy get around more people get
around the right people put yourself put
put yourself in the right environment
environment is stronger than well power
don't beat yourself up anymore did you
lose any more energy just put yourself
around people that positive
the best for you because look there's
also an energy in being a caring person
so you know when someone doesn't want
the best for you but they don't say it I
just got promoted you know oh good
that's not the response response is
amazing good for you you know so people
could say the right words but they don't
mean it
they're back it up with their energy you
want to be around people that actually
have an energy that's loves and supports
you and then also energy submit to be
passed on Energy's not so when people
say to me I'm just saving my energy it's
ridiculous thing cuz cuz you know what's
so ridiculous because as you said what
for you okay what do you saving it for
what's this big thing yeah you get
married tomorrow or something now what's
happening but here's the thing right
before an athlete goes for a run if they
go under save my energy until my one day
then you're gonna you're gonna sucker
run day you need to stop running yeah
and in the same way people that say I'm
saying
you need to stop practicing now cuz when
you when you stop there's a little bit
smarter when you become active
what happens is you then have more
energy start when you go to the gym I
don't really go to the gym because I'm
just gonna get rid of Title II you're
gonna go to the gym then you can have
energy for the rest because that's how
this thing works I think we very we need
to be self responsible as well for the
levels of energy that we bring to each
one that we enter meaning most people
just like oh I'm actually waiting for
you to have more energy even in
relationships and husband and wife is
that if you don't have too much energy
I'm just relying on you to have the
energy for me and sometimes I think we
need to do the self assessment and see
Oh where's my energy oh no no no no
let's push this up yeah and then
suddenly you change you make a decision
like you said before make a decision
that your Energy's high yeah and he will
be high and then at the end of the day
you just inspire more people to actually
become better day would you rather have
a fiery aggressive energy or an
apathetic lazy energy I'm the first one
all the way because I just don't relate
to the plastic one you know oh you've
got bad energy they might trying to fit
the cards on you are you making me feel
bad no - use not bad energy my energy is
actually a fiery energy that's making
you have to do something different I'm
making you uncomfortable
a bad energy is something that makes
people fall into apathy whether it's a
good energy so the springs people into
action
yeah but also in love I used to suppose
ruin the og in the office by accident
you know I felt that I did like let's
say you're having a meeting or
something's going on I'd come in not in
a bad way
but you also need to be sensitive
because image is powerful so if I come
in in the morning I'm like yo what's up
you know hey let's do em what's going on
but you're actually having a sensitive
moment
you having a quiet moment yeah then I'll
ruin the energy by mistake so I think
you've also got to be sensitive about
everyone about different energies about
different emotions about what's going on
I used to come into the office I'd walk
into court past 9:00 and be like yo
what's up man hey guys dude hey yeah
you're awesome and actually that's
disrespectful because people have just
had a quiet moment you had you've had
your you've just had your morning meet
you and then you've said buddy and
you're talking about a sentimental thing
and I come in and people are are in that
I mean a different and I just break into
you've got to be you've got to be
sensitive and ultimately everything you
do whether if you're being aggressive or
or or I say aggressive more like
passionate or you calling people have
been direct everything needs to be done
in love everything needs to be done
enhancing people to succeed in wanting
people to be better that's the key
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]